- [Michael] This facility was an old mine.
It was operated for about 125 years,
and these elevators are
basically a mile in depth.
And now we're in the process
of converting and operating
this as a deep underground
science facility,
really trying to unlock the
secrets of the universe.
- [Female Narrator] In the middle of
South Dakota's Black Hills,
lies the Sanford Underground
Research Facility.
Here, physicists are
conducting experiments
that have the potential
to alter our understanding
of how the universe was created.
- Our lab is unique in that
we are the deepest underground facility
for doing this type of
work in the United States.
Really, the goal is to try and limit
any sort of impurities that
can get into the experiment
that would cause problems
with our data collection.
- We're a mile underground
because that layer of
rock and dirt protects us
from cosmic rays that are impinging
on the surface of the earth.
A number of cosmic rays down
here is effectively zero,
especially compared to the surface.
- One of our experiments
that we have in the lab
is trying to unlock
questions about particles
that are fairly new in our
understanding of the universe,
like neutrinos.
- In any given second,
about 60 billion of them
pass through your thumbnail.
The irony is that this
experiment studies neutrinos
without ever detecting one.
We are looking for a radioactive decay
that can only take place
if the neutrinos play a
certain role in there.
We collect about a
terabyte of data a week.
You couldn't have taken this much data,
let alone analyzed it 20 years ago
so it's very exciting
from that point of view.
- [Female Narrator] It is the team's hope
that this abandoned mine
which once took from earth
will now help us understand
our place in the universe.
- If we understand the neutrino,
we can potentially understand
why the galaxies and the
stars and the planets
evolved the way they did
and why they're here.
- We have one Nobel Prize
under our belt already
and we're hoping that the experiments
that we have here now
will lead to additional
Nobel Prizes in the future.